touched on the letter in a covin 19
response update today
the call happened earlier on and he
explained what is next for the state
when it comes to gatherings
joe mohler live in the strip with more
on that meeting and what was discussed
joe yeah well he did discuss his
frustrations over the president's recent
visit here to the state of nevada
in addition to those events that he held
here he says we're doing pretty good
here as a state when it comes to the
kova 19 response but he would not be
surprised
if he saw an increase in cases here in
the near future
on a copin 19 response team call
wednesday governor steve cyslock
applauded the actions being taken by
residents
this did not happen by chance it is by
the hard work and sacrifices that true
nevada has made
he says cases may be down but we could
see an increase following labor day
weekend and the president's recent
rallies
he explained his frustrations about the
events and said this is why he sent a
letter to the vice president
as progress continues here he says the
mitigation task force is set to meet
thursday to determine if larger events
can happen with
more than 50 people i've asked this
group to review our current statewide
capacity and gathering limits
to see how we can make adjustments that
are nevada
and tailored for the economic and social
activities
in our state he says the group will meet
to come up with a plan as to what will
change
once this has developed it could impact
everything from church gatherings
to business meetings we asked about
halloween events and trick-or-treating
the governor says that is something they
will take into consideration within the
next few weeks
now back out here live that mitigation
task force meeting is set for 10 a.m
tomorrow we will be covering it so you
can count on us to bring you the very
latest
reporting live on the strip joe mohler 8
news now